[Music]
so the question for today is have you
ever had your heart broken yes
why didn't one got at least like two
three times yeah can you share one of
them with I drove all the way to the Bay
Area and to find out that he was still
affiliated with the bag yeah still dog
music
and I spend so much money and I do about
our luggage but I think we can't compete
with that crap but all of our memories
are because of exes like they always
come back
so I'm correct
very good olive like we can't compete
with exits so they all can values so
that's where all of our heartbreak our
heart breaks please
yeah so you mean you're like forgive a
knife then it'll happen again
yeah and then it's because it ex came
back and it's like you were suppose to
Yahoo so how many times have you gone
back together with the knife I have it I
take a back one so you just give this
advice that you're like completely going
against me I mean you have to understand
when it's somebody that's your first for
everything you gotta meet like first
love first everything
there's another nest
maybe the best advice you can even take
it so you do you really think you're
gonna end up with this guy well I do
she thinks I'm gonna marry him if he
gets you [ __ ] together I don't know how
long has this been going on for it's
like years like five years that's
[Music]
oh my god
so happy cheer on you yeah she know each
other
it was only it was like haha I'm gonna
get you back you know I mean but he
cheated with like
I say follow your partner honestly with
anything like if you deeply feel like
like in your heart regardless of what
everybody else says
maybe I'm not like that gives people
numerous chances so I know what I'm
doing is it like I feel like I'm just
going in circles
but I see following your heart you know
you mean like you feel my advice
stick to getting your money okay that
doesn't move be successful first you
can't backtrack yeah I see one more
question
yeah so you you're not are you with
anyone right now and you got so you got
together with the next once and you
learn your lesson and you have is an
essence but you're still with that
actually she came back good you ever
wonder like who you might have you ever
wonder who you might
but like yeah we mother most definitely
I feel like I've broken a couple hearts
on the way because he he's came back and
I like I've tried getting into something
new with someone
he would come back and I
so yeah I feel like I broken a couple
hearts
I don't know this is so bad alright just
like something it ending though what do
you guys want to end this video a ice I
agree get your money
get your moments on yourself especially
if you're young do that but at the same
time I mean I feel like young watch
yourself before you try to find someone
nice yeah
besides doing [ __ ]